hey guys this is dennis the founder
thing here and i'm david griffin your
resident comic looking video game guru
and this is our review of the walking
dead season 4 episode 7 yeah dead weight
so there's like the second part of kind
of like a little two-part not spin off
but a little like side story about my
governor and how he you know they kind
of showed like this thing where he he's
outside of the prison gates and then so
now they're showing how he got there and
so we finally this episode kind of
catches us up yeah to that point and
shows how he assembled a new not family
but then you go squad yeah nuvia that's
one thing though that I don't know from
this episode and the people that that
they kind of had they didn't seem the
type that were at least I didn't think
so that we're willing to like go in like
attack a prison right like get exact
some wiser or live there right I don't
know i mean i don't know maybe the
governor's that charismatic that he's
gonna be able to turn all these guys
into blood people believe what they want
to believe um yeah their parts in here i
like the word parts in here I didn't
like let's start off with some good
things first you know so people don't
start right so bad about stop watching
the show why you would notice even
watching the show get off no I honestly
if the whole the rest if we have like
some episodes the governor that little
girl that really reminded me know you
played a little bit of it read me a
little bit of the telltale Game walking
dead with Clementine and I think they
had a little thing with like the
governor and the little girl I'm fine
with watching the little show about the
govern the girls adventures across the
country but the fact that he's going
back there to the prison again just
bringing it back to Rick and then I'm
like okay but this is did I started talk
about this is I've kind of gone full
circle here with the walking dead we're
now in volume 8 made to suffer this
scene actually probably should have
already happened there's a we see we
know that he's gonna go to the prison
yeah there's some soil its flow i think
there's some stories in here that
they're building up to this took place
from vol 8 which i thought there was
gonna skip over ice and looks like the
other going back to it so well i thought
they were gonna happen the end of
last season right yeah right how'd the
big this big midseason talent finale if
you saw the trailer for next week's
episode shows a bunch of scenes that I
thought were to happen this do yeah at
the rate of last season that's why I
like it was kind of disappointing last
season when nothing that big right
happen and now they're doing it here
yeah so that kind of got me interested a
little good does that get you interested
is it looks like about the least of the
hope for future episodes well I'm
excited that hopefully this mid-season
finale will end this whole prison
storyline like right I mean I'm just I'm
guessing mm-hmm speculating that the
governor was gonna die right his next
episode maybe I don't know if he is or
not right cuz I thought he was gonna die
at the end of last year's oh and he
didn't I'm just guessing that he's gonna
die and then we're gonna resolve this
storyline and they're gonna move away
from the prison yeah so that's kind of
what I'm looking forward to and I'm yeah
I'm curious like you said I wonder how
he's gonna convince all these people
that don't seem like military types of
many other the girls you know have some
military background and the the brother
guy from fringe has a military
background but it's like I don't said
like hey wouldn't you take this with a
big tank by force and just wipe
everything out but I don't know we'll
see we'll see how a player i don't know
but like i said i don't know that part
with a the guy that played in friends
Charlie please Mitch mission this is
right I don't buy that he would have
just been like okay you killed my
brother right I'm fine with that and
I'll just follow you even with a gun to
his head I feel like hopefully next
episode maybe we'll see some maybe he'll
repeal or something because it seems
like really gonna forgive him that
quickly or at least go along with them
your brother right imagine if someone
killed a family member of yours and
you're just gonna be like all right I'm
just gonna forgive you sure you would
pretend like oh I'm with you and then
with the opportune time came you just
like right you know while they're back
was turned or whatever the hell right
come on Ike be left you guys have to
admit it's a little fast for uh we got a
Laura Thoren Tori Alicia Alicia to hook
they hooked up that I mean I don't even
know they're together until they're in
the until they were saying like wait why
are we leaving you know Tara's god
Alesha I'm like wait there together they
flirted once I mean look at me wrong I'm
a guy
I mean there's a beautiful women okay
I'm not against that but it's like
there's nothing wrong that is just that
they flirted once and then suddenly when
the governor was trying to leave their
there like in a relationship yeah deep
enough relationship where she was she
left with left with them it was like
that's not a fast yeah they kind of like
i said this moments are like again to
give the show credit love david
morrissey as a governor think he's great
I don't understand all of his actions I
guess what we do see is that he's still
crazy he has not changed even though
he's having to sketch with Martinez in
the log cabin he said you look like
you've changed like I have like maybe
he's more crazy I don't think he's
changed though but I don't like I said
things that they had if they went back
to the prison had a couple episodes
throughout the season with the governor
and little girl on some adventures I
would actually watch it I kind of like a
little girl she's cute I wouldn't mind
seeing that but I don't know but it's
his new daughter it's your daughter I'm
fine with seeing that but and at the end
he kind of like saves her but it was
like almost callously like now he's on
this revenge tip again yeah i think the
the issue with the governor they're
trying to show that he he in trying to
be a different person he's trying to get
away from that power position or the
leading position he doesn't want to be a
leader anymore he does try to get away
to give him credit he does try to leave
but there Rose blocked but yeah he tries
to leave because he sees that this this
Pete guy is weak right yes he's like
okay we just need like this guy's gonna
get us killed right this guy's week and
he's gonna be the leader and so and then
with the Martinez thing like when he
kind of offers him up and like the Koch
round the you know co leadership
position kind of flips out yeah kills
him no in response cuz he feels like he
he doesn't want that and like he's
offering it to him and even this Pete
guy kind of half offered it tonight
where you can give you some tips and
Volvo blonde right just like and so now
the governor is like fully accepted look
yeah I'm just gonna have to do be the
leader not because I want to but because
I'm the best at it right yeah exactly
yeah and I think I'm hoping is the
resolution in next week's the mid-season
finale hand so I'm hoping that what
happens in this book which she won't
spoil I hope that this gives
Ali that I think we were kind of gypped
on last year and I think even knew many
of you agree that last season's finale
was a little bit underwhelming they
hiked it up is this big showdown and
nothing really happily good thing that
happens in here died yeah for anything
he was awesome if you got reading the
comic books here we mentioned the comic
books Dennis ever the couple's read the
comment you want to hear Andrea be a
badass and Andrew be cool read this
comic andrea is awesome but now she's
still living oh yeah but not known on
the TV show and she's dead so that's it
but i hope this this mid-season finale
next week gives us a finale we were
looking for i have a feeling that i'm
probably gonna out of all the episodes
so far this season that the next episode
is the one I'm gonna like the most
because I feel like I hope so this is
what they kind of built to from even
last year yeah exactly so they you know
hopefully there's no stretching tossed
reading a story line of this episode all
right I mean then cuz I mean if this
midst isn't fala finale ends with like
some sort of cliffhanger and the story's
not result and I mission particular
stories in our result I'm gonna be upset
yeah hopefully this this delivers it
goes an exciting finale maybe like you
said maybe the person maybe just resets
the bore we just go to a different
location now which is something I love
about the comic book is it's I know
budgetary reasons that can't do it it's
constantly moving for the most part
they're never in the same location
forever this show feels kind of stagnant
I understand its budget issues I
understand but I hope that this gives us
a new maybe a new setting and a new
location I hope alright alright guys so
that's what we thought aside you can
post your comments below on the website
think here calm or on our YouTube
channel think hero pro make sure to
subscribe to that channel they got some
check us out on twitter if I talk to dad
and I about walking dead tell us you
know David agenus you should like the
show because or I agree with you or I'm
kind of on the fence let us know what
your thoughts are read the comics let us
know you know if you if you like the how
the adaptations working we're at think
here i'm at griffin de anyone else on
the facebook page that's facebook.com
slash think Harold fans make sure you
like that page and you know share our
videos on Twitter and Facebook and any
other social media outlets and really
help us out
you